bloopers offer a peek into the
filmmaking process humanizing Hollywood
stars by showing them flubbing their
lines keeping up and generally having a
good silly time while it's all captured
for posterity bloopers are especially
fun when they're from unexpected sources
such as serious actors who win lots of
awards for the dramatic roles here are
some little themed screw-ups and
goof-offs from some of the most
respected dramatic performers in
Hollywood history Marlon Brando among
the most acclaimed actors of all time
Marlon Brando disappeared into his
characters in classic films like The
Godfather and on the waterfront he lands
just the right amount of gravitas to the
role of Superman's father and a cameo
appearance in the first Superman film in
1978 but while Brando was once the very
definition of a serious actor he didn't
always take himself all that seriously
in one outtake from Superman he
transitions from the scripted poem of
trees whose branches wide and strong
into a Stephen Foster song cracking up
the crew the camptown ladies sing this
song dooda kudos Hugh Jackman a
versatile actor equally skilled to
handle costume dramas action movies and
musicals Hugh Jackman is best known for
the role of Wolverine in the x-men
series and he brings depth and nuance to
a comic book character that could be
OneNote but on the set of the 2004
Monster Hunter movie van Helsing he
doesn't even have Wolverines adamantium
claws to blame for a prop breaking in
his hands broke
no the love budget movie I'm sorry
Bryan Cranston as Walter White on
Breaking Bad Bryan Cranston was the
ominous one who knocks anyone for Emmys
for his gripping portrayal the role
involved a lot of difficult dialogue
from long monologues to rattling off the
names of chemicals and scientific
processes but it didn't prepare Cranston
for one particularly gnarly fitted
dialogue in the 2012 remake of Total
Recall I want him alive for reintroduce
re implantation I want him alive for
reinfect reimplantation Naomi Watts
while she almost exclusively acts in
really intense dramas like 21 grams and
being possible Naomi Watts lightened her
workload a little with a major role in
Peter Jackson's King Kong remake in 2005
the blooper reel for the movie reveals
an actress that has an almost
pathological inclination to swear when
she floods a line the thing that I was
afraid of is that you would be one of
those self-obsessed quick Matt Damon
he's one of the finest actors of his
generation and a beloved movie star to
booth but Matt Damon of course is not
really a genius scientist he just plays
one in the Martian most of Damon themes
in the Syfy film are of him alone
stranded on Mars carefully devising ways
that he can prolong his survival math
helps in that kind of situation but
Damon amusingly had a hard time getting
that part right
[Music]
hahahaha
uma thurman as the still ik revenge
obsessed bride in Quentin Tarantino's
two-part Kill Bill epic uma Thurman
rarely got a chance to be funny her
character is generally about as
hilarious as a hole in that like the one
Thurman makes when she reaches into a
fight opponents noggin and pulls out a
bloody eyeball JK Simmons one of the
most prolific and versatile character
actors in Hollywood JK Simmons won an
Oscar for his role as a brutal drum
instructor in whiplash which was a far
cry from his role as the soft-spoken
police chief on the TNT top drama The
Closer which is a far cry from his role
as the blustery newspaper editor Jay
jonah Jameson in the first spider-man
trilogy he's got to deliver Jameson's
lines strongly loudly and at a rapid
clip and an outtake from spider-man 3
Simmons gets at least two out of three
right congratulations son
congratulations Bach will use your shot
Bob thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to your YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to